[Music]
I wonder where you are now
I wonder if you're feeling scared I wonder if you're
hungry
?
I'm about to go back to the classroom, but I haven't found Maria yet
. It's dangerous to be alone. Come back with me.
Thank you.
Even so,
this god and his pale eyes are sparkling and beautiful There
is a route to Thailand
You have to capture a hidden character, but it's a dangerous person who has dark magic.
All his friends are going to be killed by him It's a bad
ending, by the
way, that hidden character isn't he?
I was told about the existence of a hidden character and its ending
[music]
Why did I forget such an important thing until now?
It's hard to believe that he would take the lives of people important to
him But if his memories of his previous life are correct, he has dark magic He's giving
people's lives It's scary No,
Katarina-san, what's wrong?
Do you have dark magic
? So what did you do to Maria?
Magic of Darkness
[Music
] Step 6
Namba